アメリカ研修で講義を受けていた時に
同氏を
お手洗いに行きたいと思いました
先生に
エクスキューズに応援 s ダメ主演と聞きました
すると先生はオーバーウェアと教えてくれました
こんな34みたんです
えっなにこれ見たことがある気がする
あアンパンマン出てくる
by きーマンダーと思ったんですけど違うんですね
実はこのサインの下に墓地が書かれているんです
インクルーシブレストルームと表示されていますよね
どのような意味なのでしょうか
これは性別に関係なくすべての人が利用できるをてアラーを指しています
アメリカではトランスジェンダーの方に配慮してこの言葉を使っています
私はミューザ川崎シンフォニーホールでコンサートの企画制作をしています
ホールにデイリーする人々を観察するとよく思う株ことがあるんです
この方常連さんだなとか
この形は初めての来場だろうか
そういえば最近妾なのおじいちゃん今どうしているだろう
昨年の夏に開催したイベントでは来場者の約70%が50代以上でした
40代以下の方々にももっとホールに足を運んでもらえるように私が勤めるホールを
含め日本の劇場やコンサートオールそれから
オーケストラもインクルーシブであるというようなと思いました
インクルーシブとはこのように地上にあまねく降り注ぐ太陽の光と同じようにすべての
人が利用できる
劇場やコンサート all それからオーケストラを指しています
このお手洗いで出会ったインクルーシブ
という言葉はホールの運営をしていく上で私にとってとても重要なキーワードになり
ました
このインクルーシブは日本の劇場やコンサートホールにも応用できる概念だと私は考え
ています
この視点で周囲を見回すとこれからお話をする
アメリカ研修で学んだこと3つすべてが
インクルーシブにあてはまるのではないかと思いました
アメリカの名門オーケストラピラデルフィア管弦楽団のオルガン10周年記念の
コンサートを聴きに行った時の話です
まだ演奏が始まっていないチューニングの段階で
コンサートマスターがオルガンのらのキーをタッチしただけで客席が大変盛り上がって
たんです
ここは盛り上がるところだろうか
私はこの日の雷両社は一体どういう人たちなのだろうと思いました
アメリカには1都市に1オーケストラが原則です
スポーツに置き換えてみるとわかりやすいかなと思います
地元フィラデルフィアの野球チームは
フィラデルフィアフィリーズですこの地元に野球チームを応援する人々と同じように
この日の演奏会の来場者はフィラデルフィア管弦楽団の熱心な
地元のサポーターだったのではないかと思いました
さて皆さんはアンドリューカーネギーをご存知でしょうか
彼は鉄鋼で財をなしニューヨークの音楽の殿堂カーネギーホールを立てました
このあのホールの見学ツアーに参加した時の話です
ちょうどランチタイムな時間だったんですね
だーガイドさんが約2800席ある美しいメインホールを案内してくれました
1時間のランチタイム掲額ツアーがとても有意義でまるでフルコースの料理を味わって
いるかのようでした
実はこのツアーガイドさんフルタイムで別の仕事をしながら
ランチタイムの時間にこのツアーガイドのボランティアをされているとのことでした
もしかしたらこのかボランティアさん
この日はお昼を取っていないかもしれませんけれども代わりに別の日のコンサートの
チケットを無料でいただきましたごちそうさまです
さて
若いファンを差が出るために研修先のフィラデルフィア管弦楽団が取り組んでいること
をご紹介したいと思います
このオーケストラには21歳から40歳までの人 bot 対象とした
young friends という友の会会員制度があります
範囲になってチケットを購入すると young friends イベントに招待さ
れるんです
具体的にはこちらのえっと施設内のバーでドリンクコンサート後なんですけど
コンサート子2度変更を片手に
楽団や低いさそれから他の young friends と会話を楽しむ
レセプションに参加でき
いるんです
この制度の大きな特徴はオーケストラが
young friends 自身の仕事にもメリットがあるような
ネットワークづくりに関わっているということなんです
一方をオーケストラわー将来的に支援をしてくれるパトロン候補を育てたいと思って
いるようです
それでは日本の劇場やコンサートボールそれからオーケストラも
インクルーシブであるためにできることを考えてみたいと思います
私が勤める方でホールでは主にあプロデューサー企画を行っています
これは川崎市内の小学生を対象としたイベントです
子どもたちが自分でコンサートをつくっていくんです
会議を重ねる中で企画の中身を考え
プレスリリースなど広報誌そしてお客様ご案内業務など当日の運営までを自分たちで
行います
これまでに約50名の
子どもたちがジョニーはプロデューサーを経験しました
じゃよプロデューサーを経験したら終わりさはならということではなくてその後も
コンサートホールならではの体験をしてもらう機会を作っています
具体的にはこのようにピアニストの方なんですけれども
アーティストと子どもたちが直接対応する機会を設けたりあるいはオーケストラの公演
に招待するなどしています
日本の劇場やコンサートホールそれからオーケストラもインクルーシブであることに
よって
東京だけでなく日本や世界中に美しいハーモニーが広がるのではないかと思っています
最後に私は5歳から9歳までアメリカで過ごしました
帰国してから日本で生活を送る中で学校の友人にから変えられるときがあって
後から考えるとインクルーシブ私はインクルーシブな社会いないような気がしたんです
例えば日本語の発音が違ったがおかしかった時に私はのけ者にされているな気がして
ちょっと悲しくなりました
一方
果たして私は今の私はインクルーシブな人間なのだろうかと思うときがあるんです
私は職場の通りを友人や海外の方など価値観や自分の考えた千葉黒異なる方と接する時
に時々心のシャッターが降りていることに気付いたんです
この心のシャッターを意識的に開けることによって自分自身もインクルーシブな人間に
なっていくのだと思っています
ありがとうございます